Well we have a special treat for everyone on board this evening.
We can get a real live performance by some of our guests
joining us on this flight this evening. We'd like to
welcome aboard the Princeton Choir. And I believe they are
going to show us (laughter) Stand up Quinton! (singing)
Well we're about to go to rehearsal at the Bethlehem
Chapel. And it's really famous because, like, Jan Hus
preached there in Czech for the first time ever. Well, I
mean, the first time it wasn't in Latin. (singing)
With a choir from the United States and a choir from the
Czech Republic singing both American and Czech songs is
really at the heart of good diplomacy.
Behind us is the Stephansdom, or St. Stephen's Cathedral in
Vienna, which is where we performed last night which was
super exciting. It's one of the top sites in Vienna so.
And because of our concert we have now helped to raise some
money for restoration on the roof.
And we just got a standing ovation when we did our show at
the Stephansdom. Oh my gosh it was so amazing.
Coincidence had it that both the Choir and I were here in
the same week. I had a concert on Tuesday, two nights ago,
at the Theater an der Wien. The Chapel Choir provides me
with some of my best memories from Princeton.
This is St. Stephen's Basilica, the biggest Roman Catholic
Church in Budapest and we're about to perform an impromptu
concert. Enjoy!
It had such a strong impact on the choir that it was
important to do this as often as possible. Part of what
happens with a choir is because they're together for so
long they get to know each other better, they trust each
other more, and the sound of the choir changes. So when we
got back it was a fuller sound, it was a richer sound, and
people knew each other better. So it was a marvelous
experience altogether. Our Monday rehearsal after we got
back from the tour was pretty much chaos the whole time
because everyone was so excited to see each other again.
They'd been away from each other for, oh, 24 hours and
couldn't wait to see each other again. So that told me that
this tour had had a big impact on their relationships.
You can have recordings, you can photographs, you can have all
of these things but the experience of singing it is
ephemeral. It touches you, it leaves its mark, and then it
goes away. The actual experience goes away but still it has
0:03:41.01,0:00:02.27
touched you in a way that is indelible.